翻訳: rina funabashi
校正: Hiroko Kawano
僕は今一輪の花を使った
アート作品を通して
世界を変えようとしています
アートと聞くと
皆さん どんなものを想像しますか
絵画
彫刻
建築
ちょっと詳しい人は現代アート
そして 最近流行りのラテンアート
こんなふうにアートは
形を変えて存在しています
なので 必ずしも
美術館という空間の中のある物が
アートというわけではないんです
では そもそもアートの定義って何でしょう？
アートとは？
この答えは 人それぞれだと思います
そして 僕はアートをこう定義しています
「嗚呼と」
「嗚呼」という言葉の意味は
喜んだり、悲しんだり、感動したり
そんなふうに心が動いた時に 発する声
例えば
花火やプロジェクションマッピングを
広い意味でアートと捉えるならば
あれって 言語や文化背景を問わず
「嗚呼 すごい」って言いながら
誰でも楽しめるじゃないですか？
そう考えた時に
僕 気づいたんですよ
心が動いた時 どの言語でも
人は必ず「嗚呼」って言っているなって
「嗚呼 なるほど」って思ったあなた
今「嗚呼」って言ってますよ
（笑）
思わず口開けて「嗚呼」と言ってしまい
心を動かすが出来るもの
それが「嗚呼と」だと僕は思います
この定義を元に今取り組んでいる
アートプロジェクトがあります
プロジェクト名は
『スプレッディング・ラブ』
日本語に訳すと『愛の拡散』
それではまず こちらの映像をご覧下さい
（音楽）
（音楽終わり）
この スプレディング・ラブは
一輪の花を まちなかで配る
ただそれだけです
お花には一言だけ
メッセージが添えられています
「あの人へつなぐ」
前から気になっているあの人
最近ケンカしたあの人
大切な あの人
お花を受け取った人は
自分が思い浮かべる「あの人」へ
お花をつなぎます
それを受け取った人は また次の人へ
そして また次へ
何か見返りを求めることもなく
ただ与えるだけ
ギブ・アンド・テイク ではなく
ギブ・アンド・ギブ
そんな無償の愛が
一輪の花と共に
人から人へ伝わって行く光景は
きっと アートなんじゃないか
僕はそう思うんです
実はこのプロジェクト
僕が始めたわけではないんです
どういうことかというと
以前 京都へヒッチハイクをした時の話です
その時に車に乗せてくれたのが
黒柳徹子にソックリなおばさんだったんですね
（笑）
目的地に着いたので
「ありがとうございました」と言って
車から降りようとした時
そのおばさんは僕にある物をくれました
それが 一輪のお花だったんです
そしてそこには
「次の人に渡して下さい」と書いてある
メッセージカードが添えられていました
そのおばさんは 娘から
お花をもらったそうですが
その娘もまた 別の人から
お花をもらったそうです
つまり誰が最初に始めたかが
分からないんです
僕は戸惑いながらも
そのお花を受け取り
次に乗せてもらったおじさんに
感謝と共にお花を渡しました
その時人生で初めてだったんですね
他人にお花を渡すということが
小っ恥ずかしいというか なんというか
でも そこで気がついたんです
お花を渡した時 心の中で
「嗚呼 いいな」って思ったんです
つまり 一輪の花をつなぐという行為が
僕の心を動かしました
もしかしたら これは
僕が定義するアートなのかもしれない
そう考えたんです
人から受けた恩を
その相手に返すのではなく
別の誰かにつなぐ
このお花をつなぐというプロジェクト
最初に始めた誰かの意志を継いで
世界中に広げていこうと決めました
そして いつか
僕にお花をつないでくれた
おばさんのもとに
またお花が帰っていけばいいな
って思っています
この 『スプレディング・ラブ』に
共感してくれる人が増えてきています
これまでに開催した国は
日本、台湾、韓国、オーストラリア
そして これから
中国、アメリカ、イギリスで行います
それでは実際に
スプレディング・ラブに参加してくれた
人たちの声を聞いてみましょう
（女性）お花をもらってくれる人が
笑顔になってくれることが凄く嬉しかったです
嫌な気持ちだった人
元から気分が良かった人
色んな人がいましたが
その人たちの笑顔の時間を増やせました
言語は通じないけど
それが嬉しくて 私も幸せでした
（男性）愛を無償で与える側の私たちが
愛を頂いたような感覚になりました
このような愛の連鎖が
世界でもっともっと起こっていけば
幸せな未来になる気がしてなりません
与える側であるはずの参加者も
いつの間にか 大切なものを
受け取ってたんです
だって考えてみてください
見知らぬ人に 自ら話しかけて
お花を渡すことって
すっごい勇気がいることなんです
特に日本人は 疑ってなかなか
お花を受け取ってくれません
（笑）
だけど そこでお花を受け取ってくれた時
お花を配る側の心も
「嗚呼 良かった」と動かされるんです
お花を受け取った人が
笑顔になるのを見て 嬉しかった
お花をなかなか受け取って貰えず
ちょっと落ち込んだ
そういった
喜びだけではなく 悲しみを含めた
あらゆる感情をもたらす —
心を動かす何かを
感じ取って貰えた時
それは僕が定義する
「嗚呼と」になります
お花を渡す側が
勇気を出した時
お花を受け取る側が
疑う事をやめた時
それがきっと
無償の愛がつながる瞬間だと
僕は思います
では この無償の愛の連鎖が
一体 何を生み出すんだろうか？
このプロジェクトを台湾で行った時
お花を受け取ってくれた人と
友達になりました
その友達が先月
なんと名古屋に遊び来てくれたんです
お別れする時に
日本語で書かれた手紙を
僕にくれました
そして メモを見ながら 一生懸命
日本語で手紙を読んでくれたんです
僕 それを聞いている時
ちょっと 泣きそうになりました
手紙には 何度も書いては消してを
繰り返した跡や
所々に 間違った言葉遣いもありましたが
その子の気持ちはしっかりと
感じることができました
たった一輪の花をきっかけに
こんなつながりが生まれるなんて
誰も想像できなかったと思います
思わず「嗚呼」と言ってしまい
心を動かすもの
そんな目に見えないアートだって
人と人とをつなぐことができる
それが 『スプレディング・ラブ』なんです
この誰が始めたか分からない
スプレディング・ラブ
特定の誰かの利益とか実績とか
そんなのはどうでもよくて
ただ純粋に みんなで
楽しみながらお花を渡す
それでいいんじゃないかって
僕は思うんです
そんな無償の愛が世界中に連鎖したら
一体どんな世界になるんだろう？
お花を渡す文化が
生まれるかもしれない
国を越えたつながりが
人種や宗教を超えたつながりだって
生まれるかもしれない
僕はその続きが見たいんです
皆さんは たった一輪の花から
どんな世界を想像しますか？
ありがとうございました
（拍手）